So we now focus on the Eulerian paths
problem
and try to learn more about de Bruijin
graphs.
So, we saw that to reconstruct the genome,
we
need to find an Eulerian path in this
graph.
But some of you noticed that I cheated.
I constructed the de Bruijn graph from
genome, but in real life, genome is
unknown.
The only thing that is known is reads or
k-mers.
Can we reconstruct the de Bruijn graph
from genome composition rather than from
genome?
Well, let's try to do this.
But let's first review what we have done.
What we have shown is that given a genome,
we can construct the de Brujn graph.
What we want to do is, given genome
composition, or
k-mer composition of the genome, we want
to construct the genome.
What we will show now is that given k-mer
composition, we can construct
de Bruijn graph and then using Euler's
insight to construct Eulerian paths in
this graph.
Let's start.
So in the past, we started
from a path representing
the genome.
But now the genome is unknown.
What is known is only composition of the
genome
And we will represent this composition,
every element, every
3-mer in the
composition by
an edge.
We will now construct also nodes of this
graph by representing them as
2-mers as we did before. Now, to
construct the Bruijn graph from k-mer
composition, let's do exactly the same we
did before.
Let's just glue identically labeled nodes.
For example, AA and AA identically
labeled, let's glue them together.
Bring them a little bit closer, and
finally glue.
Let's continue with AT, the same thing we
see continue, continue,
continue, continue, continue, continue,
continue, continue again.
More, more and finally they're getting the
same path
that we were getting as if genome would be
known.
What we haven't done yet is gluing because
they are, of course, other vertices to
glue.
And we proceed exactly the same way as we
were proceeding in
the case when genome was known and finally
construct the de Brujin graph.
So what we have just shown that even in
the case
genome is unknown, we can construct the
same de Bruijin graph
as in the case the genome is known, and
this is great.
Which means that the next step we need to
address is how to find Eulerian paths in
the graph.
So, for construction of de Bruijin graphs, the
algorithm is very simple.
We simply need to represent every K-mer as
an edge between
its prefix and its suffix, and afterward
glue all nodes with
identical labels.
It is a 2-line
algorithm.
If you implemented that you have already
figured out that there is a different
way to look at de Bruijn graph. If you are
given the collection of k-mers,
we can form nodes of the graph from all (k-1)-mers
from this collection, and
for each k-mer from the composition, we can
connect its
prefix nodes with its suffix node by an
edge.
This is our two equivalent definitions
of the de Bruijin graphs.
And now let me explain what was de
Bruijn's contribution to
this area and why these graphs are called
de Bruijn graphs.
De Bruijn graphs have great applications
of biology, in biology.
But de Bruijn of course did not know this,
because he was interested in purely
mathematical abstract problems. He tried to
solve so-called universal string problem,
which is finding a circular string
containing each binary k-mer
exactly once.
Here all eight binary k-mers.
Can we find the strings that contains each
of them exactly once?
We can.
This is the string, and if you check for
each binary 3-mer, you will find it
appearing in the string along the circle
if you travel around the circle clockwise.
For example, for this 3-mer, it appears
along the string.
But how can we construct the string?
Is it even possible for all possible
values of k?
Well, the only thing we need to do, we
need
to represent each of these binary k-mers as
an edge.
Right?
Because it should be a k-mer composition
of the string we are trying to find.
Afterwards we need to construct the Bruijn
graph from this
isolated edges and then the Bruijn graph will
look like this.
And afterwards, simply look for Eurelian
cycles in this graph.
Cycles rather than paths because de
Bruijn was interested in finding circular
strings.
Can you find an Eurelian cycle in this
graph?
And how can it help us to find universal
string?
Let's
see.
Let's start working here, and we
immediately can
get insight into the first three elements
of the string.
Let's continue this way, and when we
travel through the graph, the string
keeps enlarging and enlarging and
enlarging,
and finally, we constructed the universal
string.
The fact that the graph is Eulerian implies
that every k-mer appears
exactly once in this circular string.
But what about this four
universal string constructed from all
4-mers.
What about ten?
All 10-mers in this case, the graph will
consist of thousands nodes.
Does it have a Eulerian cycle?
If yes, how can we find it?
We'll answer this question in the next
segment.